das ist wirklich der hammer es waren
bisher insgesamt 220 hammerschläge
zunächst 20 sehr vorsichtige darauf
folgten dann zwei mal je 100 schläge und
dann machte sich unendliche
erleichterung bei den fachleuten der
nasa und des deutschen zentrums für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr breit denn der
mars maulwurf der mars sonde inside
gräbt wieder
doch wie konnte das gelingen und wie
geht s weiter klicks um science fiction
die gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann und nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
das war wirklich spannender als jeder
krimi doch der plan der nasa und des
deutschen zentrums für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr ist aufgegangen zumindest
vorerst kommt der mars maulwurf mit dem
bohren voran das so tillmann spuren vom
deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr die eindeutige
vorwärtsbewegung ist ein gutes zeichen
und bestärkt uns in der hypothese dass
dem auf die reibung sozusagen der grip
fehlte der fortschritt zeigt uns auch
dass kein felsblock unseren vorfahrt
blockiert das sind großartige
nachrichten nachdem der mars maulwurf
also mehr als ein halbes jahr lang in
einer tiefe von 130 zentimetern
feststeckte hat er sich jetzt innerhalb
von einer woche um immerhin zwei
zentimeter weiter in den boden bewegt
auch wenn das erst einmal nur ein
kleiner fortschritt ist deuten die
fachleute es als erfolg denn das
vorankommen zeige klar und deutlich dass
die eingesetzte strategie die richtige
sei hilfestellung kam vom roboterarm der
sonde die dem bohrer seitlich an das
gestein drückt und so für die notwendige
reibung sorgt dazu nasa-mitarbeiter treu
hudson der maulwurf hat noch einiges vor
sich aber wir sind alle begeistert in
wieder bohren zu sehen hierbei klick zum
science und fiction haben wir immer
wieder über den bohrer der mars sonde
inside berichtet anfang des jahres 2009
10 war an den start gegangen doch schon
nach rund vier stunden endete seine
arbeit in hat dieser tragödie 4000
hammerschläge lang klappt alles super
doch plötzlich ging gar nichts mehr und
der maulwurf kippte sogar seitlich um 15
grad eine panne die nicht nur ärgerlich
sondern auch wahnsinnig teuer ist und so
tüftelten die fachleute monatelang an
verschiedene möglichkeiten den nasa
maulwurf wieder zum graben zu bringen
das große problem die fehlende reibung
an der seite genau das steht seit juni
19 als ursache für das problem fest
damals hatte der roboterarm das gehäuse
des bohrers angehoben und offenbart das
ist der raumsonde wohl ein seitlicher
reibung fehlt und genau das wird wohl
auch weiterhin das große problem bleiben
denn wie wird es weitergehen wenn der
bohrer sich so weit in den untergrund
eingegraben hat dass der roboter haben
ihnen nicht mehr von der seite stützen
kann
fraglich ist ob er dann alleine weiter
vorankommt für den fall der fälle sind
die fachleute bereits jetzt dabei einen
plan b für die nächste bohrphase zu
entwickeln
falls der bohrer dann erneut stecken
bleiben sollte könnte möglicherweise
geröll helfen denn damit könnte druck
ausgeübt werden der für das graben
notwendig ist die experten und
expertinnen von der nasa und dem dlr
überlegen aber auch inwieweit der
roboterarm eingesetzt werden könnte dazu
tilman spohn wir werden den boden mit
der schaufel belasten um in geringen
tiefen etwas mehr druck auf dem maulwurf
zu ermöglichen
doch das muss äußerst präzise und
vorsichtig vonstatten gehen da aus der
oberseite des bohrers empfindlicher
sensor kabel herausragen der
langfristige plan der fachleute des jet
propulsion laboratory der nasa und des
deutschen zentrums für luft und
raumfahrt ist jedenfalls gigantisch die
raumsonde soll sich bis zu fünf meter
tiefe in den mars boden graben um dann
den wärmefluss aus dem inneren des roten
planeten detailliert zu erkunden
ermöglicht wird das durch die
kombination aus bohrhammer und eines
temperatur senders dörfer ich kann die
wärmeverteilung im maß gemessen werden
und vor allem auch die beschaffenheit
des mars innern analysiert werden wir
werden also eine menge über den mars
erfahren wenn alles klappt wenn exomars
macht mobil vom neuen kanal in unseren
wissenschafts netzwerk es 1054 hyperraum
tv einen beitrag über extras also die
baldige europäische mars-mission mega
fundierte berichte also an kriegen
anschauen und abonnieren also ganz kurz
aaa bis dann bleibt dran